this is a production of cornell
university
morning everyone
uh just to
start off
the hemp
website up there cornell hemp
all of the work we've done from a risk
and economics perspective has uh been
posted there and will be posted there so
we're going to
just
kind of
run quickly through some of the recent
work and then uh you know we'll be
updating uh that material on the website
so
two topics today
uh risk management in the hemp industry
and then also some farm level economics
funding
for the first project was northeast
extension risk management
and that was with lindsey paschall
myself and heather darby from vermont
and then the economics was uh
funded by farmville viability institute
and that was uh myself uh lindsay
savannah shellna and daniela vergara
okay so
really quickly
i'll be talking about five different
sorry yeah five different sources of
risk uh in agriculture
production
marketing uh legal human resources
and the financial risks
uh possible strategies what we found for
uh
you know this was a work group that
met several times so
understand and implement best management
practices
uh was was one of the keys
uh timely information regarding legal
considerations uh price points further
research regarding optimal production
systems and practices
and then a possible solution for some of
the risk was
vertically integrate
the cost and returns analysis that we
did
showed that what we did we looked at
three different production systems a
greenhouse high tunnel
and outdoors
and the revenue uh above variable cost
was negative 3.84 negative 3.65
and 1.78 dollars per plant for the
greenhouse greenhouse high tunnel
and the outdoor horticultural systems
these results are very sensitive to
variability and some of the key factors
we've looked at percentage of cbd and
also
the price
there are a lot of others that um
and i'll mention a couple as we we move
through
uh let's move through so risk i just
wanna so we're we're all familiar with
some of the concepts we used for that
first project
risk is variability and outcomes or
events a chance that what you expect to
occur will not in agriculture you plant
a crop in the beginning of the year you
have some idea in terms of what yield
may be
at the time of harvest
but it's not certain you don't know what
that yield is going to be
uh so that's the that's an example uh
characteristics
when we talk about risks we recognize
the variability
but
one of the things that is a
characteristic of when we speak of risk
is that we have historical data that we
can draw from uh for
uh yields for example a farm has uh
generally yields over time that they can
look at to establish a mean and a range
etc uh with something like hemp
unfortunately we're putting together
that uh some of that historical data so
risk versus uncertainty is uh
is something that we have to be thinking
of
so the sources of of agricultural risk i
mentioned those production market
financial legal and human resources
production is just
anything to do with growing uh
harvesting the crop market and price of
course uh quantity sold at uh at what
price financial is just uh
traditional profit uh other measures of
economic performance the legal aspects
are one that are uh
very critical for the hemp industry and
uh tends to differ quite uh a lot from
what our traditional uh farm business
owners have to deal with and then the
human resources aspect
uh strategies avoid reduce retain
uh self-insured shift so
a lot of a lot of people that have an
industry they've applied for licenses
etc but they're they're avoiding the
risk they're just not going to take
those enterprises on at this point
reduce
pest management aspects for example uh
contracts
which i'll mention here in a bit uh
retain you just go about and
go about the business as you you think
is best and and hope for the best
self-insure set aside some uh
capital or finances for
those cases where you may find that i
wasn't able to harvest the amount that i
wanted to
and and now we're you know it's
affecting the financial aspects of the
business
and then shift move it to somebody else
have somebody else bear that risk crop
insurance is an example where you know
you're
an insurance company is accepting your
premium and they will cover you in the
event of a loss
uh so this is the risk management
project again uh this material will be
on the uh the hemp website
i'm really not going to
spend a lot of time on that other than
uh
we had about 100 individuals
participated in one or more of the
project activities we had a web-based
survey we had two industry meetings one
in new york and one in vermont
and then we hit in field days and we had
small group meetings where uh
representatives from the different
points in the supply chain
met to discuss risks what were some of
the underlying causes and potential
solutions
we'll just
quickly
i think i'll just go right
to uh
what were some of the solutions that uh
the group came up with
so
in terms of marketing um you know we the
group talked about vertically
integrating
so a farm business owner uh for example
they
when we're talking about the sources of
risk in terms of marketing and the
underlying reasons uh people were
mentioning things like i i don't have
control over the product beyond
you know the farm gate
uh how do you do that you know how do
you address that risk and so one thing
that
we talked about was vertical integration
so
process in in some of the other uh
activities of the supply chain
this contract aspect
it's very important that you
understand best management
practices for contracts and larry and
mary ulrich put to
put together
a nice
piece that's available on the website
that
tells you what a good contract should
look like and they're very important
for
ensuring that
you know people understand what's going
to be delivered what quality what price
will be paid and then any uh
you know
sort of repercussions if uh you know the
contract isn't executed uh correctly
so that's an important uh piece that and
that's already in place i i don't know
if mary and larry have plans to uh
revise it but
uh on the website again is uh is a very
good resource for that
this next one is one that will sort of
lead into the the economics and
increasing the capacity to determine
price points so that was a
aspect of marketing risk that was
mentioned
and
and what what we talked about was that
uh you know we
we want to determine that it's important
to determine the price points but we
need information for example the cost of
production uh yeah i can look at a price
that's out there but what are my costs
of production how do i evaluate and
assess whether that
price is uh favorable or not
so they're the cost of production work
that we we've done in the economics of
the farm level has been uh
has has been a key way that we're
responding to that but we probably need
to look at that up the supply chain as
well in terms of what our price points
etc
you know beyond
the farm production level
testing capacity
uh that
i think probably that was one of the
topics that was talked about most
in terms of uh
clarification regarding uh testing
requirements
who has to do it who's going to bear the
cost
how much can a grower for example
spread those costs over
plants or acres so that was a
that's that's a critical
source of risk that was talked about
and i think
we're not i'm not sure where that uh
that goes as is someone that kind of
stops at the farm level uh that'll
probably be something that the industry
is going to have to address
uh cooperatives were also mentioned as a
way to
uh
improve not only the marketing
of the output but also obtaining inputs
etc
see okay uh and then
the legal risk contracts uh
you can see the a lot of the same things
become repeated because they're they're
interconnected the legal the financial
uh the marketing uh
and they they all
at some point uh tend to affect each
other
uh
i think i'm just gonna
this this will be on the uh
you know on the website and i think it
it was on the handout that was provided
for this topic
so the other uh aspect of the work is a
cost to production analysis
you saw
back
on the previous slide where we talked
about sources of risk in terms of
marketing establishing price points
so one of the key things in terms of a
grower is
what are my costs of production how do i
evaluate these different price points so
we've spent the group has spent quite a
bit of time
looking at cost to production first for
fiber and grain and dual purpose we uh
did some work a couple years ago on hemp
cbd in an outdoor setting and then this
work was put together to look at
different production systems
so
uh
i'll just kind of i like to acknowledge
the uh uh help of uh several growers and
processors
there that uh
did some q and a sessions with daniella
and uh and and others so
that information was very valuable in
addition to
uh you know what we had from our from
our experts
um and then the the cornell agritech
research
trials groups so
those are sort of some acknowledgments
we're looking to estimate the value of
uh
a production costs and returns for hemp
by
cbd production system
all right so here's the first uh
set of uh results that i'd like to talk
about
so what we have are the three
uh production systems greenhouse high
tunnel in outdoor or in a horticultural
setting
and where
establishing a time frame is critical if
you're going to look at
you know an analysis like this looking
at others there are a number of other
states that are putting together
information uh one of the key things
probably you want to start with if
you're comparing is look at the uh the
differences in any time frame that's
looked at so we're starting with
transplants so we start with the value
or the cost of that transplant
and then we follow the activities of the
process process through to the plants
are hanging to dry
so that's the
that's the scenario that each of these
uh different systems
uh is examined under
so
you see that the the variable inputs uh
fertilizer well
hemp so six dollars per plant uh initial
assumptions were uh one pound of uh
biomass per plant at a six percentage
point per pound of biomass and a dollar
uh per point so those were the original
assumptions uh so there's the the six
dollars per plant
uh fertilizer and lime are very similar
of course except for the outdoor
horticultural because there's a cover
crop going on
and so there's there's a little
fertilizer to establish that that cover
crop
uh seeds and plants um
again we used a dollar twenty so when we
had our group uh work a dollar for the
seed and twenty cents to establish
that was what we agreed upon
the outdoor setting includes some uh
cover crop seed
uh this is a factor that when you're
looking at other
uh
other analyses
you really have to pay attention to
uh you know what's being used there for
example
there was some work out of alabama
earlier this year
and i was looking at that and looked
just to see where our estimates were
falling in
into place
and
the comparing to this to the our work to
the alabama work it was
the the costs were much less and
it's
one of the things is they use the four
dollars per plant
for uh the transplant so
so the results are going to be very
sensitive to
those
uh those kinds of things
uh sprays
a biofungicide for the indoor settings
uh and then other inputs other crop
inputs
we've heard uh we talked a bit about
testing
this morning so testing is the big a big
factor there in terms of that
category
um and just that there was a question
earlier about what are some of the fees
so
we used
uh about 300
for
a heavy metal
pesticide residue tests
and then
there was a testing fee of about 250 to
300 for
the traditional thc and other testing so
you can see that
you know for a given crop
or a given year
that's a pretty significant number
and so that's where we talk about
who's going to bear that cost can it you
know and that sort of thing so our
assumption there
was that
we took half of the cost and put it into
that spray
uh or other crop inputs
so that's where
uh you know that the indoor settings are
going to be at a disadvantage they're
spreading that cost over fewer units
whereas the outdoor setting uh you know
we're looking at uh 15
100 plants
per acre the indoor setting was 120
plants for one
one growing season
uh so that's that's a major difference
between the systems at this point
and really
i think someone mentioned earlier or i
saw at some point the you know sort of
the disadvantage of those indoor systems
on a fairly small scale
uh labor of course is a is a big one
uh
indoors
or in the greenhouse setting
the uh
the key there was uh
that's about 31 hours in terms of uh
labor hours
and the uh
a lot of that is in pruning
that's where the vast majority is
and then we have
uh probably five to four dollars for
harvest uh
it's and this is for the structure
uh miscellaneous daily cat tasks uh and
then some cleanup and that sort of thing
so
those are the those are the hours for
the the indoor setting
uh the the out um for the greenhouse and
then the
the high tunnel is similar
in terms of what's going on there in
terms of the cost per plant
and we see that the labor for the
outdoor horticultural
is
is about half
and
there's mechanized planting the
transplant operation is mechanized with
the tractor a planter and two people
so
you know that's contributing to a lower
per unit cost
and then
actually that then the outdoor setting
gets pretty uh expensive when it comes
to the labor that's used in terms of
pruning harvest and and hanging
all right so the uh
those are the some of the keys that that
i wanted to uh get out there that those
are the results were uh that we have
today
uh we're working on this project
probably for the the end of the end of
the this year to
finalize and
come up with some
firmer estimates
you can see that the returns uh there
again that's what i mentioned earlier
returns above
variable input cost
negative
almost four dollars per plant for the
indoor settings and then a dollar eighty
for the uh for the outdoor setting
again a lot of this is the ability to
spread some of those
um you know like the testing fees and
other costs
uh that are fixed like licensing etc
over greater units
okay
let me just there's some sensitivity
analysis uh
i think i just wanted those so the that
last bullet item there items
just make sure that you understand the
time frame used
the value of these transplants seem to
vary at least the what's what are being
used in the analysis very quite a bit
the product testing expense and then
labor charges
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu